a war is coming
i'm afraid your friends at hawkins are
very much
in the eye of the storm
[Music]
i don't have my powers
without you
[Music]
we can't win this war
i wanted to go ahead and ask you both
though about
this season knowing where it's gonna go
and where you guys began because it is
so much darker than the first three and
how maybe refreshing that was for you
guys to watch the series mature
alongside you and millie i'll start with
you yeah i mean obviously it's
it's weird because the story is growing
while we are growing i mean in height in
in everything so it's actually quite
it's quite sweet um in a way because
it's something that
we can go through altogether
um and the deaf brothers definitely like
to write on
what we're going through like i actually
funny story in season three broke my
kneecap in half and they wrote in that
11 gets her on her left leg so they
really do write to us so it's quite
sweet that the show does grow with us um
i think that's something that i've
always really enjoyed is like i'm not
doing something drastically different
because they kind of write to
who we are as people
yeah and no i'll tweak it a bit for you
what was something that you got to do in
season four as a character that you're
like okay
this is definitely new was it the whole
roommate thing because i have to feel
like that is just such an incredible
wrinkle that they gave you guys here
no totally i mean season four as a whole
for will is just something new and
something fans have not seen and have
kind of been begging for is to see will
in a hat and he's not happy and settled
yet but
he's not being attacked by the
demogorgon or the upside down and he's
kind of just struggling with his
personal
identity and with high school and and
you definitely get to see that side of
him and it's very new and and
interesting for the viewers to see
well i do know that you guys have
developed and the entire cast for that
matter of friendship over the past four
years but as the two of you i know are
very close
is this like something where you're like
okay we can live out our roommate
fantasies because then we don't actually
have to live together as friends and we
can pretend this is like our little
college dorm room setting did you guys
get to do any of that
yeah i mean we
make the duffers write us some stuff
together so because we want to work
together so
the
this is definitely
like kind of our chance to work together
and live out those
dreams yeah
although i would love to be your
roommate yeah
ever since you left everything's been
a total disaster
for a while we tried to be happy
normal
i know that's impossible
no something i actually like manifested
i remember writing in my like journal
saying like i want to be on a show where
i grow up and i get to watch myself like
i wanted to be on a show with a lot of
kids and have fun and ride bikes on set
but i don't get to do that because 80s
run after you say don't do that don't
jump off of that but like it's um it's
really like it's awesome you can i can
go back and look at a younger version of
myself like just like wow i'm really i
was really like you know working like i
was really doing my thing you know it's
wholesome and i get to grow up with
these guys these guys and i'll know them
for the rest of my life like genuine
like you know good people that i know so
it's it's a blessing a lot of people get
to have that i guess me and erica are
kind of growing together you know when i
started this i was about the same age as
erica i'm a little bit older than her
now maybe like a year so i guess we're
kind of i've kind of put some of my
personal experience that i'm going
through as a teenager and to erica so
we're very relatable in some ways um
and it's cool seeing me grow and i'm
learning new things and
so is erica in the show so
it's really cool i think it's gonna be
great for viewers to see the the group
having been broken up i think it adds a
really cool dynamic uh there's
not there's a lot that we can't really
fall back on uh uh very easily when we
are when we go into season four and it
allows for a bit of a different dynamic
and a different strategy that we're
gonna have to uh have to
we have to make a different type of plan
when going into dealing with our new big
bad and it's pretty pretty exciting
yeah i think they can definitely expect
her to be in a little bit of a darker
place than we've ever seen her before
you know she's in a lot of pain and how
she kind of copes with that is by like
putting this wall up with with the
people who care most about her um and
that ends up kind of hurting her more
than anything really and her thoughts
just kind of like start to eat away at
her and she kind of feels like like a
ghost of a person
in in some moments
see on the other side
on the other side
[Music]
yeah i definitely felt that way when we
sat down for the table read and i think
it was the first time that i had read
the scripts and i think we read about
four or five maybe six of them and right
away it was like
this is
way darker and it's going to be far more
grotesque you know the old seasons it
was like kind of had some of the
elements of like those 80s horror movies
where it's a little bit of a wink at the
camera but this this one goes there you
know that kind of like the magic of
childhood has been ripped away and
um i'm excited to see what people think
of it
yeah i mean i feel like every season has
kind of had um
you know a slightly different tone and
like flavor to it and sort of it kind of
touches on a different aspect of these
you know this this era and these movies
that it's
referencing um but this season
felt
particularly
grown
in a way like that it definitely feels
like you know these characters are
encountering i mean it's always been
quite serious and you know
the things that they're encountering but
it's like this something about this
season does feel um quite i mean still
light and fun but there's there's a
seriousness and like a weightiness to
what they're going up against which is
just interesting to see how these
characters grow in those situations
[Music]
oh well i think kind of it was a very
kind of funny wink to the 80s that they
kind of with this character
they were able to kind of
access the kind of the the whole kind of
satan hysteria satanic hysteria about
dungeons and dragons and for eddie to be
that kind of like vessel for that i
thought that was kind of a really
interesting way to kind of bend it
um
but yeah it was it was very exciting
it's such a i think to kind of join
something like this it's just pure magic
you know it doesn't happen very often uh
that something is so adored by so many
different people of different ages and
so to kind of be able to kind of
participate in that and kind of i guess
contribute to that is uh
is a yeah a once in a lifetime kind of
thing so yeah
it's amazing
well kind of who you find me with today
in this room um i mean they're their
character
avatar versions and some other awesome
people um i'm really
i don't know i i
i just feel so lucky about my team um
this season and both kind of
from the way that i think the chemistry
works in the
show it's just totally magical and also
the way that the
chemistry worked off set which is like
we're all just like
making jokes and winking at each other
and laughing and having a kind of great
time and so
i don't know that was that was great
we're bantering
we're getting to know each other oh yeah
and we're gonna good push-pull dynamic
yeah we are we're doing we're thinking
we're doing a lot of thinking we are
thinking
you've broken everything
your suffering
is almost
at an end
it happened organically it was pretty
pretty wild like i know i first like
i read for the part of eddie it was
interesting and when i got when i was
asked to read again
and it was for a different sort of
character they didn't even tell me the
name yet they was just like a sort of
stoner guy
and uh
and then like i was like uh i was told
by by uh sean and like finn that that
like
finn had gotten a hold of like the
scripts like ahead of time
and uh he had read it some of it and
like he saw the argyle part and he had
asked like the duffers and sean like hey
have you guys gotten someone because he
was like you guys should get this dude
eduardo
this was like before i even knew him
which was pretty like crazy like when
they told me i was like i did i had no
what the [ __ ] was like because i was
already auditioning for like other parts
i didn't even know about that and they
were like yeah they just thought of
bringing me into it and i felt so like
i'm like eternally grateful for that man
it's like it's like a an honor to be a
part of it so
argyle brings out a totally different
energy with jonathan which was just like
so nice to play it was like able to kind
of take the shackles off a bit and you
know even though everything that he's
going through and struggling with he's
kind of got this birdie now to be like
yo um
and uh yeah they they their dynamic just
kind of works really well for each other
i think i mean i feel like you're doing
a lot of service for jonathan what do
you get what does jonathan do for you
yeah i mean i think i think it's like i
think it's like uh um
i think it's it's like it's like a great
uh friendship
it's like a judgment-free zone i'm
saying like he's finally able to like
voice his his feelings and open up about
it which is hilarious like the guy he's
opening up to is like he's not the not
the brightest guy
so it's hilarious that like that's who
he's like trying to like sort of like
not necessarily get advice from but he
might get a couple inserts here and
there that where like i'll get through
to him and then he'll be like yeah
you're right and it's like
i guess yeah i guess like uh what what
argyle would get from jonathan i don't
know i think it's just yeah a nice
friendship man yeah maybe like a maybe
like a consistent one man maybe one
that's like
open to everything like that's like
probably the coolest friendship they
have is it is it friendly like
judgment-free one
the show has matured you know with its
audience and with the characters and uh
and i think that's what they're able to
kind of do that now especially now the
kids are getting so much older uh so the
themes have got darker and they're all
they're able to kind of like uh you know
use as influence darker material and i
also think there's a shock value to that
i don't think people i don't think like
i think the level that they've stepped
it up in horror this season is so much
it's like it is drastically much more
scarier than the third season so
i was convinced i was put here for some
other reason
maybe i can still help
even if it's the last thing i do
first of all i have to say i'm going to
start with you winona because you've
starred in some of my favorite horror
films from you know dracula i think you
know you could even make an argument
about black swan as a horror movie so
how did you feel coming into the season
knowing how deep they were going to you
know dive into that world you know i
remember
coming on to this show like
being very nervous that it was sort of a
genre and those movies were so long ago
and they they did have this element of
horror but it was also like you know
coppola and you know just it was very
grand
and um
this season
you know we we go really hardcore um
it was really exciting i mean it i i
think what i love so much about this
season is that
and and and the duffers
is that they
have managed to
um
really accelerate like all these story
lines but they also really managed to
keep the heart of the show
i mean everyone is in in they're
fighting for survival but they're also
fighting for love
you know in every
sense the kids growing up
that awkward
you know
high school like that that all that kind
of stuff that often gets written off of
like oh they're kids oh and just i'm
talking about in life
but that's like when you're a kid things
are just as painful and confusing
as
any anybody else as as older people and
and on top of that they're dealing with
all these
unthinkable like bizarre
monsters literally
actual manifestations of what you think
about yourself when you're a teenager
but like
gigantic and an alternate universe it's
it was new for me i don't think i've
ever done a genre quite like this it's
it's a genre of itself i don't want to
take up too much time no no i'm glad you
said that because you're right yours
were very genre and horror movies but
they weren't like this where like they
are really trying to scare the pants off
of folks but i think the fans are gonna
dig it eyes a fan dug it and david i
have to say with you
it's been a minute since we've had this
and the world's been obviously so locked
down but i'm sure you still had
interactions mask on with like fans
running up to you having to say stuff i
have to hope it was about the letter
because that is such a fan favorite
moment so just clue us in on any like
what is the number one thing fans come
up to you and say
or want you to say to them okay i'm just
waiting
they say uh they think and i'm a big
much more than literally that's uh what
people want nowadays i mean they
you know i i you know but what part of
this show or what's there
i mean hopper's such a complicated great
character
yeah you know
i mean and the kids love their these
[ __ ] but like i think he's so
sorry yeah no no no i i i mean i it's
funny my fan base i'm like uh a very
middle-aged man and i thought my fan
base and i thought like the trajectory
of my career would go into this sort of
like art house world of like plays in
new york and like this and now my fan
base truly is like i can't walk past the
middle school without like people like
poor children just running at me oh okay
brett just really quickly fleabag or
stranger things which one do you have
more
uh it's a draw it's a draw okay well no
i'll say stranger there you go
stranger things
you know
because it's now it's happening fleabag
is of the past stranger things is of the
presence
people say hawkins is cursed
they're not
way off
congratulations on season four the first
thing i want to go ahead and talk about
is the clear nightmare on elm street
vibes and sort of what was the decision
to go in this sort of darker more
horror-driven i would say tone for this
season it was something we decided
really early on it was a couple things
one was season three was you know it was
kind of our fun summer blockbuster silly
season and we always want to try to do
something different it just felt
naturally like we just wanted to pivot
and go in a totally different direction
and the other thing that really informed
it was the fact that the kids are not
kids you know they're teens and they're
in high school now and
you know us and our writers started just
talking about our high school
experiences we tend to all be
nerds none of us had a good experience
in high school like it was a rough four
years and and even the people who have a
good high school experience it is a
challenging very you know tran in a
transitional period in your life like
where where you're i think there's a lot
of nerves because it's like you're kind
of moving from childhood into into
adulthood and people can be particularly
mean there's a lot of anxiety there's
depression there's some there's heavier
things like we started to talk about
this and it was like it was like oh
we're going to be exploring some heavy
themes and this is on top of all the
trauma that our characters experienced
at the end of season three and it was
like we have to deal with that so it
just felt it felt heavy and it felt like
it lent itself to a more
intense adult psychological horror like
it's not jurassic park anymore a
telrazer it's nightmare and elm street i
mean those were the references that we
were
pulling from so that's really why we
went there i just like that the kids
getting older they're not kids but it's
just forcing us to evolve it just keeps
us all on our toes it makes every season
feel
you know feel different and i think
that's that's what we really wanted to
do each one feels
very different from the preceding season
yeah and i think that's the really fun
thing about each year is it seems like
you know you guys got the gang together
and then you just did the process of
once you found great pairings just
switching them up and giving us new
pairings and that's kind of been the
really fun thing about this season is
seeing these new pairings how do you
guys decide that is this like a board
where you just like put the faces and
the paragraphs
some of it is planned
you know it's like okay i want to see
robin and nancy together like what is
that you know you're just like that'll
be interesting and you know and also
when we get to know these actors and
then it's also why
despite our cast being as large as as it
is it's like why we like to throw new
characters in there every once in a
while why we introduce you know the
character of eddie it's just like you
want to
why we split our characters apart
because you just want to shake up these
dynamics to keep it fresh so it doesn't
feel like you're doing the same thing
over and over again but in the case
sometimes like the steve dustin pairing
that a lot of people really responded to
in season two that was an accident that
was not planned that was we were i think
halfway through writing
that season and
dustin had nowhere to go and steve we
had no story for steve
and we're like what is and then ross and
i just were like what if
maybe they get together is that crazy so
and so that was kind of like a discovery
but it always feels like a science
experience experiment you never know
what kind of a chemical reaction you're
going to get with these pairings but why
not try
and because it's that's what's created
magic for us before so we're just like
well let's see what happens you know and
it usually works out and i think it's
because you guys have written this world
so vividly looking at the cast photo
from the premiere last night it's crazy
to think when we were at comic-con in
2017
and you guys were just like the toast to
the town after season one but one of the
things that's been a through line has
been the soundtrack and the fact that
you guys have been releasing this on
spotify i listen to it all the time very
quickly talk about the music
for season four and again how you guys
rewrote the script on that very quickly
if you don't mind
yeah are you 80s music or score original
i mean score score like i'm gonna go
ahead and do that
sorry oh that's please
that's us well i mean it's i mean you
know for us when we were coming over the
idea i mean very early on we decided
that we wanted to try
synth for it because it could like if we
were to do orchestral it was just going
to feel like we were trying to mimic
john williams but we you would never get
there on on a tv schedule like that it
would just it would always just feel
smaller than what we would want that to
be and so very early on we cut a little
trailer to help sell the show and that
was in in you know we used a bunch of
you know movie clips like e.t and some
of the in some horror movies in
halloween and we just put it all
together and then we put john carpenter
on there and then we also put
survive
uh which is the band that that two of
the guys from that band score our show
and suddenly it's like well that is
pretty cool to put you know elliot
walking up to the shed and then to have
synth on it it just it suddenly gave it
this feeling a very unique feeling and
we're like this has got to be
the sound of the show and so it's
obviously such an integral part of the
experience and it was this year was
really uh fun because there was a lot of
pre-production and we told kyle and
michael who are the composers we said
why don't you guys just
don't don't look at any picture
just you read a couple scripts and then
just whatever comes out just give it to
us and so we have like we had hours of
of just material that then we were able
to sort of mold to the scenes that's
what we did season one so it's like we
returned to how we approach the music
more in season one i'm really excited
about it so like the mechanism
convective theme and all that that just
came out of this exploration i mean i
guess it was yeah it was years ago now
that they were just just playing around
with without seeing any picture at all
so that was it was a fun experience
their music this year is yeah
you